- I'm Hilde Lisko.
And I'm a reporter.
- This is for the people
who don't believe in you.
- My dad's a reporter, too.
(police siren)
- You're back in town?
- Just got in.
- You two know each other?
- It's been really nice
and quiet around here.
This is a warning.
- Where'd you get all that?
- At the crime scene.
- Crime scene?
- When he left, your dad said
he would never move back here.
- How come?
- In '88, the mayor's kid
went missing.
- They never found out
what happened to Richie.
- Is that... Dad?
- My best friend.
He was taken...
right in front of me.
- I want to see
the police report for Richie Fife.
- Can someone deal with this?
- I'm not going away.
- I can't show you everything,
but here's what I got.
- Why are you helping me?
- I don't like when they
pat me on the head, either.
- Young lady, you have no idea
what you're getting in to.
- I feel like being called a young lady
should be a compliment,
but it never sounds like it is.
- What did you do?
- I'm a journalist!
- You're a fourth grader!
- There's a town full of people that
know more about my husband than I do.
- I think there's something
you should know.
♪ Runnin' 'til I'm home ♪
- I know you cut school to
interview a murder suspect.
- No.
Well, yes, but no.
♪ Runnin' 'til I'm home ♪
- In our family,
we work out our problems together.
♪ Runnin' 'til I'm home ♪
- Be smart.
- I'd rather be brave.
- Be both.
♪ Runnin' 'til I'm home ♪